diot 37 squeeze aujourd'hui seront pour
une compilation de jeux on commence tout
de suite avec gouaille simulator c'est
un simulateur d'herbe très palpitant
lesparre mode select et plusieurs modes
très bien classés grâce dubstep orange
va lancer en classique et envoyer les to
do ouais saviez peut-être un peu trop
doux quand même c'est un peu chiant et
on connaît dans un prêt avec des vaches
qui ont des espaces de grosses passe au
un chrono à sa relance il tord nickel et
du coup est ce que la vache va lever 7
est au ralenti non non mais les gars
allez gamme et qui a fait ce jeu déjà un
mais c'est horrible c'est déjà chiant
que le temps était normal mais là c'est
d'un ennui profond [ __ ] oh oui le
temps est revenu donc plus jamais on
prend ce truc c'est carrément
dégueulasse il ya tellement peu de
choses que c'est même pas drôle un
caveau elysées de l'herbe des armes quoi
et les vaches qui n'a pas terminé de
modéliser ok on va passer au mode
de grâce voilà ok donc là je suis de
l'herbe c'est ça ennuie simulateur ayem
mais non c'est du blé pardon j'ai cru
que ces mauvaises herbes c'est un peu
nos ennemis boyle bleus viennent en tant
qu air de la pluie alors reds adacore
donc c'est un simulateur des rebonds se
trouve attiré au gadjo des cibles ça
c'est pour les développeurs parce que
j'ai de la peine quand même je sais pas
mais c'est comme si jouer à tetris et
que le but c'est de tuer des bourses
avec une épée ça n'a pas de sens mais si
d'armes au corps à corps les simpson
qu'est ce qu'on fait et ce qu'on tape ce
[ __ ] de bus raya pas développeur la
taper comme ça de hopper de jeu allait
way suivant où la s'est passé un truc là
dans cette gorge
ouais un gloss suivant alors attendez
reste le mode d'obstacles un truc là on
est d'accord il devait avoir un truc en
quoi sa mode d'obsèques [ __ ] c'est un
mot de passe rien et ses vaches sont
morts et en paille et [ __ ] merde dans
leurs relances pas normal ah bah voilà
ça marche
donc c'est juste ça voilà deux sets -
doit faire tourner les pages sur le même
mode terminé et j'ai trouvé la page ken
lampe torche mon gars il est où le haut
ou duo le plaçait à danser mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe
la plus grosse semaine de tous les torts
ça se passe ici dans ce chan ces genres
de soirée que voir dans paris à toulouse
à marseille et partout dans la france
on sait maintenant que j'allais twitter
et se mettre bien le soir on le sait
finalement penser qu'ils s'ennuyaient
mais pas du tout mon cas il s'éclate
avec en outre le ciel se met à danser
aussi très bien s'arrêter là joué assez
de conneries le regard du mois de
l'arbre danser ça va ce top sujets
suivants je suis outré ou très bon temps
des bombes à ce jeu suivant ou pas voilà
on est sur le ring face simulator donc
ça consiste à jouer à flight bieber tout
en mangeant des céréales d'après ce que
je vois et ça fait assez drôle et si
vous savez faire deux choses en même
temps
moi je sais pas du tout faire deux
choses en même temps et c'est pour ça
que j'avais fortement envie de tester ce
jeu j'ai acheté la version complète
on pourra jouer à d'autres jeux flapi
berne on va commencer avec la pub hearts
et party down the left side of the
screen pour georges labit bird et sweepé
pour manger aux caisses partie aux
[ __ ] en fait je vois même pas les
céréales je suis je me concentre
uniquement sur fuck your bird
je préfère mourir de faim mais avoir un
bon souffle à piper d'assas et 2014 mais
c'est fun ah non voilà faut jamais dire
que c'est facile avant d'avoir vu que
c'était pas si facile que ça mais on
sait ça ta [ __ ] depuis hier il a ils
avaient bloqué à kehl mon camp je meurs
le mec il a chaque cuiller et tous les
blessés quoi arrête ses flops bird
arrête ça suffit on s'en fout du soir
ont fait se pointer du doigt c'est plus
simple que le a
pourquoi chez moi je dis
c'est ça dont je fais un rapport avec la
facilité quelconque ça devient dur de
regarder vous avait il un spasme eux
carrément y dégage son bol et tout ce
que j'aime bien c'est que la mare de
gauche est vraiment bien fait ça c'est
on notera l'effort d'aidé développer un
et sur un bon feeling là vraiment
regardé hop là qu'est ce qui se passe
bas oui je mange ou un flambeur doigt le
problème et je n'aurais jamais puisque
je fais que de gagner regardé et je suis
sûr que ce jeu ne va pas du tout ma
préférée choses en même temps voilà 192
et alors on est quoi rang 6 et ça sert à
quoi laurent vu personne joue à ce jeu
dans le monde je peux pas me vanter
auprès de mes amis géométrie dash
on est déjà nul sur faire enrager de
céréales en même temps mais alors là ah
oui d'accord ils ont vraiment fait eux
mêmes à larache le fait que dash voit la
paille de géométrie d'acheter une
version nul et la dessert à l'infini
parce que je vois que tout à l'heure je
mange mange mange mais ce qu'un moment
il doit remettre des céréales et que
l'on doit faire trois choses en même
temps
et bien franchement on a bien plus de
niveaux sur son jeu mais tri d'achat lui
et pour la belgique bat vente plus tard
et est ce que si je reste appuyé sur sow
t il saute deux fois non non je suis
mort à cause de ça ok je suis scandalisé
or il ya un classement mois 192 points
tient à 16,72 1580 points mais ça fait
quoi ça vous savez que tu as mangé deux
tonnes de céréales et que tu as fait 620
sur fleury birds c'est ça mc âme je suis
mieux pour faire de trucs en même temps
c'est incroyable énorme d'eiffage parce
que je suis un homme et que les hommes
ne savent pas faire du tout en nous
faisant débat tout de suite c'est ça que
vous voulez ce sac du mot [ __ ] de
break face à lui la torre kopter alors
celui là je suis d'une nullité à les
entendre les 72 mille china on arrive on
est dans ton rétro voilà voilà soixante
dix huit de koné dans ton rétro mais
loin d'être très loin enfin la boucle
sur ce ring kopter c'est un peu
compliqué quand tu as le ski négatif
après j'ai voilà voilà voilà voilà ma
vie me laisse même pas parler pour dire
je suis l'une le montre avant même que
je le dise ah [ __ ] mais arrête de
regarder ton bol [ __ ] c'est pas toi
qui te prennes fait ces dernières fois
ci c'est toi mais bon bush maman elle
est pas content de tout nettoyer
derrière hockey qui a envie de jouer à
flight bird au réveil au réveil je dis
bien le moins envie que personne te
parle août à un vrai zombie
il se dit je vais faire comme ça je vais
rage et dès le matin et je vais bien
passé une bonne journée de merde faut
que china puisse nous voir au télescope
uniquement voilà elle a fait 70 missions
femi elle peut nous voir avec un avec un
microscope même je dirais pour la
séduire il faut lui dire que tu as fait
au moins ce qu'ont entrepris voilà là on
en est loin
bah oui avec un petit 72 de merde 68
voilà bah voilà bah là on croise tyan
elle nous fait bas alors t'as ptet
étaient au chômage touchent moi je t'ai
pas vu ton travail
voilà hélas 0 on la revoit elle fait
battait mort le décès la latte et été un
des témoins en fait finalement ton nez
on n'est pas loin des pas mal on est pas
mal s'il vous plaît pas de musique
épique non non non non
voilà qui est le mec qui met les
musiques dans mes [ __ ] de vidéos
c'est moi eh ben je me déteste et je
vais me pendre avec ce casque est ce que
vous aimeriez un peu comme se détendent
tous ensemble 1 allée boisée temps venez
prenez place vraiment asseyez vous les
voyez votre problème soit sur mes genoux
soit sur mes genoux voilà je suis un
dangereux psychopathe ou juste là vous
mettez avec la super nanas juste là vous
allez c'est parti ce que je sais c'est
que ce délire ça fait tellement du bien
je comme ça à colorer un petit peu
mignon partout après ce [ __ ] de break
face machin est possible tout you tube
voilà et moi je suis adulte 1 je tiens à
préciser je paye tout un enfant a besoin
pourquoi on tire ça sert à quoi y avait
pas de méchant mais il ya un du tout on
va s'envoler vers le ciel pour explorer
l'inexploré c'est beau ça comme
foisonnant et c'est lui je lui tire
dessus peut tirer dessus
oh mon dieu ça rebondit mais ça c'est
franchement quand tu déchire un jeu
comme flickr de quoi il devrait le faire
décharger ça en même temps un mais ça ça
tire dessus ces conneries tu es un
vilain de montgolfières au pays des
rondoudou qui me veut du mal
nex nouvelle miss et 100 m ouais mais
attends mais attends mais en fait je
rampe en fait je glisse ses sa a vu avec
pioupious au [ __ ] ça me saoulait là on
est sur un jeu trop mignon trop kawaii
en est là le retour et galérer condé
plus d'abeilles à la foule on bat le
taper petit esquif c'est bon pour du
coup on a perdu pas mal de vie mais on
est en vip c'est tellement beau regarder
voilà vous avez regardez moi non à la
méchante us travel fédé gauche droite
gauche droite
[ __ ] j'ai même vu à une latte de
league of legend elle n'y a pas
longtemps
oh oh là là une embuscade non j'ai
compris que je ne m'en offusque anne ont
repoussé fdp d'été c'est tout ce que je
voulais dire oh le monde est beau à mon
dieu un cas non plus une abeille c'est
trop on sent les troupes pour nous elle
envoie son dard comme ça elle faisait
cette tête je vous promets je les
buveurs
moi je voyais juste nous poser sur un
transat et regarder les nuages ou un peu
comme l'a en fait continue aux
directions cette grande pointe jaune
durées longues n'ont beau match voilà ça
c'est fait fin boum boum boum be sent le
chip sqbb ça veut dire un bail en
anglais ok j'ai compris j'ai fait la
tête que vous avez fait rire c'est de là
que j'ai vu là j'ai imaginé en tout cas
et ça m'a suffit vraiment j'insiste oh
mon dieu non plus qu'à nous ohlala on va
sur le petit racaille ou volant voilà
dans l'extension
non non ça c'est un dieu sait que
bakayoko avait trahi bodmer non je peux
pas je peux pas ah non mais je suis
dégoûté [ __ ] on se retrouve là voilà
une bonne claque noir dégueulasse
polluée au web à l'annoncé de la fin de
cette vidéo gta ça vous a plu et ça
c'était fantastique journalisme sans que
j'aie pas d'illusions ce dernier jeu
trop quoi
j'aiderai si vous a plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo comment faire au
revoir comme squeeze mettant le doigt
sur la tempe et pis voilà là franchement
vous avez été splendide
voilà ce que je vous ai vu encore une
fois je bon ou trop ou trop aller ou le
trot à genève
[Musique]